8 news now live at five
now that people ages 70 and older can
get the covid19 vaccine more and more
places are starting to offer it
good evening to you thank you for
joining us at five i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez smith's grocery
chain announced today that it is now
taking appointments for this week eight
news now reporter joe moeller joining us
now live from a local smith's pharmacy
with what you need to do in order to
make that appointment for your vaccine
joe getting a vaccine
is getting easier for some the state has
been working to get
vaccines into your neighborhood
pharmacies and smiths just like this one
here at decatur and flamingo
is going to be the first to get it in
the state and this all starts tomorrow
as of today smith
is taking appointments for people who
are ages 70 and older to get the vaccine
each smith's pharmacy plans to
administer 100 to 200 a day
appointments must be made online you
have to allocate around 30 minutes to
get the shot in time to be monitored
for a possible reaction dan heller from
smith's pharmacy says they are happy to
be joining the fight against this virus
and are now hiring more staff to help
coming in and getting your vaccine once
you've scheduled yourself and made an
appointment is as simple as going to
uh the drop-off window of a pharmacist
like you're dropping off a prescription
completing the consent form that is
required for any vaccine
finally then the pharmacist will come
over and do a review
on the topic of vaccines the restaurant
industry wants to make sure workers are
vaccinated as well clark county
commission chairwoman marilyn
kirkpatrick held a virtual discussion
with the restaurant association to
hear concerns i also spoke to the
co-founder of taquettarian
who believes restaurant and hospitality
workers should be moved up
in the line to get the vaccine food and
agriculture
is right under teachers and restaurant
workers should be in that group with
food and agriculture which includes
every other step of the food supply
chain farmers
butchers delivery distributors everyone
who touches food
except for the people that are actually
handling the food and serving it
directly to the customers are not
included
right now the state gets around 35
thousand vaccines
a week kirkpatrick says they hope to
give out more vaccines to more groups as
more allocations are allowed for nevada
reporting live here at decatur in
flamenco jim mullin 8 news now all right
joe thank you for the